السلام عليكم تظاهر مئات الاهالي في مدينه
رفح الحدوديه المصريه احتجاجا على هدم
منازل محايه لقطاع غزه في اطار عمليه
واسعه لهدم الانفاق على الشريط الحدودي مع
القطاع نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لن شه من
زاويتين ما هي الدوافع الحقيقيه لاقدام
السلطات المصريه على هدب هذه المنازل في
رفح وما هي التاثيرات المحتمله لقرار
السلطات المصريه بهدم الانفاق على الحدود
مع
غزه في اطار عمليه يبدو انها موجهه ضد
الانفاق الرابطه بين رفحه المصريه
ونظيرتها على الجانب الفلسطيني هدمت
السلطات المصريه ثلاثه منازل على الشريط
الحدودي بين رفح وقطاع غزه وكانت العمليه
التي بدات قبل نحو اسبوع قد ادت حسب مصادر
في رفح الى هدم ثمانيه منازل قبل ذلك في
ظل غياب تصريحات رسميه مصريه توضح على وجه
التحديد اهداف العمليه وعدد وطبيعه
المنازل التي
تستهدفها لله امنيه تبدو الاشد في سيناء
تواصل القوات المسلحه المصريه هدم منازل
وانفاق على الحدود كانت تربط سيناء بقطاع
غزه وتكثف عمليه البحث والتمشيط في محيط
المنطقه المستهدفه مع فرض طوق امني مشدد
عمليه الهدم بدات منذ نحو اسبوع وتستهدف
عددا من المنازل ويقول الاهالي انهم
ابلغوا بخطه امنيه واسعه قد تمتد بطول نحو
11 كيلومترا هي امتداد مدينه رفح مع حدود
غزه وبعمق قد يصل الى 250 مترا لكن
العمليات الراهنه تنحصر فقط في المنازل
التي يعثر بداخلها على انفاق وحسب ما هو
متداول فان السلطات المصريه تبرر عمليات
الهدم بانها تهدف لقطع طريق دخول الاسلحه
والذخيره والمخربين من غزه الى سيناء
اضافه الى وقف عمليات التهريب الاخرى ولا
ترى السلطات اي علاقه للامر بتضييق الحصار
على غزه وتصف ما ري بانه ضمن استراتيجيه
التامين والحفاظ على سلامه مصر يذكر ان
سيناء ومحيطها شهد اعمال عنف متزايده خلال
الفتره الماضيه استهدفت الجيش والشرطه
وكان اشدها دمويه مقتل 25 مجندا في اغسطس
الماضي بايدي مسلحين مجهولين نصبوا كمينا
لحافلة حه للقطاع وليس لسيناء والجماعات
المسلحه التي تستهدف الجيش والشرطه والامن
وهنا ربما لا تجيب العمليات الراهنه على
الاسئله المهمه المتعلقه باولئك المسلحين
ونشاطهم في سيناء وكانت محافظه سيناء قد
طرحت عام 2008 فكره انشاء منطقه عازله مع
قطاع غزه بعمق 500 متر لكن الفكره واجهت
اعتراضا شديدا ادى الى وقف تنفيذها حينئذ
واستبدلت لاحقا بانشاء حديدي نفذ بطول نحو
4 كيلومترات فقط وتوقف العمل فيه قبل ان
يبلغ المنطقه السكنيه التي تستهدفها
العمليات
الحاليه معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور جمال نصار رئيس منتدى
السياسات والاستراتيجيات البديله من باريز
اللواء ياسين سند المحلل العسكري والخبير
في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه وعبر
سكايب من القاهره اللواء اركان حرب عبد
الحميد عمران الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا
نبدا من باريس واللواء ياسين سند برايك هل
من تفسير واضح لهذه الخطوه المصريه الخاصه
بهدم الانفاق والبيوت التي توجد بها
الانفاق مساء الخير اولا وتحياتي
للمشاهدين مساء الير الموضوع بتاع الانفاق
ده اساسا موضوع امن قومي الانفاق كانت جلب
من الداخل ومنن الخارج يعني من الطرفين
اسلحه معربه من ليبيا بتروح غزه واسلحه
بتيجي من اسرائيل ومن غزه لمصر ومخدرات
واعضاء بشريه وفي عصابات وحاجات كتير جدا
فموضوع امن قومي
يعني الانفاق لازم فعلا تترد وتتقفل وفي
معبر موجود بديل وفي معبر بتاع اسرائيل هو
اللي بيروح منه الحاجات الاساسيه وعندنا
المعبر للركاب والحاجات دي موجود بتاعنا
نقل الناس دي طبعا القوات المسلحه لن تترك
اهلنا اللي موجودين في رفح من غير ماقوى
يعني الناس اللي اتهدمت بيوتها دي اكيد
هتعمل لها ماقوى بس بعيد ليه لان هم
الانفاق كانت بتبقى مفتوحه من داخل
الدولاب في اوضه نوم يفتح في في بيت اني
على الناحيه الثانيه لانهم طبعا العائلات
مترابطه وكان بيتهرب البترول اللي هو مدعم
من عندنا وبيتهرب ويتباع بست اضعاف سعره
وكان في تربح شديد جدا للناس اللي بتقوم
بعمليات التهريب دي فطبعا ده كان ضروره
علشان الامن القومي المصري يتحفظ عليه
النهارده لو حاولوا يزودوا ويفتحوا
الانفاق في مسافات اطول هتطلع في منطقه
مكشوفه ممكن على طول تتكشف فطبعا المشكله
الاساسيه عندنا في التمشيط الخشن اللي
بيتم في سينا بقى له فتره اللي هو الناس
اللي بتلج للاماكن الماهوله بالسكان ف
طبعا دي بيبقى في حذر شديد من ناحيه
القوات المسلحه وهي بتنشط لان فيهم بعض
الناس من الاهالي ومن القبائل وكده فبتكون
العمليه هاديه ولكن الحقيقه قبائل في سينا
كلها كانت متعاونه وقامت بدور رائع مع
القوات المسلحه في تصفيه جيوب كتيره جدا
يعني جبل الحلال الحمد لله نضف كماما
مافيش فيه حد ههم بس الجيوب البسيطه اللي
موجوده بتختبر ماهوله فيها كثافه سكانيه
موجوده نعم طالما ان هذه الخطوه
هي نعم طالما هي امن قومي تحديدا نريد ان
نسال ضيفنا في القاهره اللواء اركان حرب
عبد الحميد عمران تقديم الموضوع على انه
امن قومي وضروره يعني تقريبا لا فكاك منها
هل
يجعل حجج السلطات المصريه فيما اقدمت عليه
مقنعه سواء للاهالي او للراي
العام مساء الخير مساء الخير لا شك كان
الموضوع موضوع امن قومي حقيقي وليس خداعا
او شي من هذا القبيل لا يعقل ان الحدود
تكون مفتوحه بلغ عدد الانفاق في وقت من
الاوقات 1800 نفق لا يعقل هذا الكلام في
اي دوله في العالم لا في اوروبا ولا في
امريكا ولا في اي حته فلابد من اغلاق هذه
الانفاق انا اتفق مع الاخ ياسين تماما
ولابد من استخدام المعابر الشرعيه الرسميه
اللي هي عليها كنترول اللي هي بتعلم من
يخرج ومن يدخل فيها لكن ان تظل هناك تجاره
لا تعلم حقيقتها ما بين مواد غذائيه ومواد
بناء الى جانب الاسلحه والمخدرات لا يعقل
هذا الكلام لابد من السيطره عليه ومصر
بتتخل الاجراء الصحيح لحمايه ابناها
القومي وحمايه حدودها وليس نكايه او عندا
لا في قطاع غزه ولا في اهل سينا ولا شيء
من هذا القبير على الاطلاق انما هو امن
مصر القوم نعم ولكن حضره اللواء بالنسبه
للبيوت التي بها الانفاق مثل ما اشار حضره
اللواء ان يمكن النفق ان ان يخرج في غرفه
نوم هذا البيت او ان يخرج في دولاب هذا
هذا البيت الم يكن بالامكان غلق الانفاق
دون الوصول الى حد هدم
البيوت لو الموضوع متوقف على بيت او بيتين
او 10 كان يسهل هذا الكلام انت حض تتكلم
عن كم كبير من هذه البيوت وانت لا تعلم ان
هي طالعه في في ان حجره وفي اي مكان وانا
اعتقد النهارده كان مطروح على القنوات
التلفزيونيه ان مصر ببب تعويض الاسر التي
هدمت منازلها عن المنازل بتاعتها فيعني هو
امن قومي ويتم تعويض المتضررين عنه بلا ا
غبن ولا ظلم لهم يعني نعم دكتور جمال نصار
ضيفان وبالطبع هما كلاهما من خلفيه عسكريه
اكد على هذا البعد الامني في ما اقدمت
عليه السلطات المصريه هل تراه هو البعد
الوحيد فيما يجري مع في رفع بطبيعه الحال
لا يجب ان يكون البعد الامني فقط هو الذي
يتم التعامل من خلاله مع ا اهل سينا اهل
سينا يحتاجون الى تعمير يحتاجون الى
اهتمام اكبر ولكن للاسف النظام البائد
نظام حسني مبارك كان يتعامل بهذه الطريقه
بالفعل بنفس الطريقه وبنفس الاسلوب وهي
الطريقه الامنيه فقط ولعله ا الامر قيل
كثيرا انه لابد من تعمير سيناء لابد من
ادخال اصلاحات الى اخره
واعمارها بالبشر لانه فكره موضوع تعمير
سناه موضوع اخر ومعقد لكن الان امامنا
حاله واضحه وهي انفاق تروج بضائع مختلفه
مثل ما تابعنا وبالنسبه للسلطات المصريه
تعتبر ان هذا ليس لا من باب التضييق على
القطاع ولا مناكه حماس وانما هو مساله امن
قومي هل تعتقد بان هذه المساله هي فقط
امنيه اولا فكره الامن القومي اصبحت فكره
يعني غير محدده المعالم زي برض فكره
الارهاب ويصفون اي انسان بانه ارهابي
ويلبسون التهم ثم يقولون انه ارهابي الى
اخره انما هنا احنا عندنا زي ما قال س
اللواء عبد الحميد عمران انه حوالي ما
يقرب من 1800 نفق انا مع فكره اغلاق كل
هذه الانفاق بلا ادنى شك ولكن المشكله
الكبرى هنا في لابد ان
نعوض كل من هم في غزه من الناحيه
الانسانيه هناك طلاب يدرسون في مصر هناك
لابد من مواد غذائيه هناك مرضى ياتون الى
مصر فاذا تعويضهم من خلال معبر رفع هذا
امر في غايه الاهميه هوو انساني بامتياز
النقطه الثانيه استاذ محمد فيما يتعلق
بطريقه تعامل القوات المسلحه مع المصريين
وهدم منازلهم بهذه الطريقه الغير انسانيه
فكره انهم اعلمهم قبلها ب 24 ساعه هذا
كلام غير صحيح وايضا لا يجوز يعني يجب قبل
ان تهد هذه ال مباني او الزء المساكن لابد
ان توجد لهم
بديلا مناسبا واضحا انما فكره ان انا
اخبرهم ب 24 ساعه واهدم عليهم هذه المنازل
بحجه هذه الانفاق هذه الانفاق كبيره
وكثيره ويجب ان تتعامل مع المساله من كل
ابعادها انما ان تهين الشعب المصري بهذه
الطريقه انا ارى ان العنوان الاكبر هو
اهانه كرامه الشعب المصري بشكل او باخر
ولكن طالما ان الموضوع امني بالدرجه
الاولى كما يقول ضيفان هنا اسال اللواء
ياسين سند موضوع الانفاق ليس جديدا يعني
تقريبا سنوات وطرحت كثير من الحلول البعض
تحدث عن جدار حديدي تحت الارض البعض تحدث
عن حتى عن
ضروره مجرى مائي بين رفح المصريه
والفلسطينيه برايك لماذا
الان نزلت القوات الامنيه بهذه القوه
لانهاء الموضوع رغم انه ممتد
لاشهر
وسنوات يعني ذكرك بحاجات بسيطه كده سريعه
ليها تاريخ يعني لو رجعنا لسنه
2004 كان تنت اللي هو مدير المخابرات
الامريكيه طلع
معاش راح راح الرئيس المخابرات السابق عمر
سليمان يعني يقول له حمد لله على سلامتك
وهابي لاندين وكده فبلغوا تنت بان في مخطط
لاننا ياخدوا 1600 كيلو متر مربع من سينا
ويحلوا بيه مشكله غزه علشان يخلصوا نهائيا
من المشكله
الفلسطينيه
بنظير 80 مليار دولار لما عرف الموضوع ده
وبلغ الرئيس الرئيس طبعا ادعي جدا و وقف
حتى عمليات
اسمام ترعه السلام اللي كانت هتمشي لغايه
اسرائيل قال لا مش هوصل المايه لاسرائيل
وبدا يسيب الانفاق لفتره علشان يساعد اهل
غزه عن قصد لكن العمليه تطورت فيما بعد
وبعد كده جه بوش الابن برض طلب من
الرئيس محمد مبارك حسني مبارك نفس المطلب
في مره اخرى فبطل يروح امريكا وبعدين لما
جه حتى اوباما عشان يكمل المشوار بتاع
المشروع اللي هو بتاع التقسيم ده ما قابلو
واعترض على مقابلته علشان ما يتكلمش في
الموضوع ده ففي حاجات كتيره جدا خافيه على
الناس ناس مش عارفاها النهارده احنا في
موقف البلد فيها سيوله
وفي العمليه بتاعه الارهابيين اللي كانوا
موجودين في
سينا
والمجاهدين
والتكفيريين
والقاعده كانوا زايدين قوي واعدادهم ضخمه
اللي كانوا في مناطق مفتوحه كان سهل جدا
التعامل معاهم اللي كانت في مناطق موجوده
مهوله كانت محتاجه ل الحنكه وخبره وتعاون
مع الاهالي وبعدين نفتكر بقى اتكلم في
الحته اللي مهمه جدا ال 25 اللي اتقتلوا
دول هم علشان باتوا في العريش ليله وتعرف
انهم هيمشوا الصبح وكانوا رايحين فاضل لهم
اربعه ايام ياخدوا خف يطلعوا رضف طالعين
من
الاحتياط النهارده مسكوا الولد اللي قلهم
تهم اللي في الموضوع ده كمان اللي قبله
اللي بتاع السبعه اللي اتخطفوا السبعه
اللي اتخطفوا لما القائد العام بلغ الرئيس
محمد مرسي ان في سيطره على المكان بتاع
الخاطفين والمخطوفين طلع على الهواء يقول
يعني حفاظا على ارواح الخاطفين او
المخطوفين حط الخاطفين قبل المخطوفين وطلب
من القائد العام ساعتين ويرد عليه ليه في
الساعتين دي خلى الناس تهرب وسابوا الولاد
لوحدهم وبعدين راحت القوات المسلحه جابتهم
فالعمليات اللي بتواجهها القوات المسلحه
كانت فيها جهود صعبه لتعدد العوامل
الخارجه عن الاراده ولا بد من الحفاظ على
اهل سينا لان دول اهلنا ارجع للجزئ بتاعه
تعمير سينا تعمير سينا يعني يعني بعد اذنك
فقط يعني بعد اذنك بعد اذنك فقط حضره
اللواء موضوع تعمير سينا موضوع متشعب كبير
حتى نبقى في موضوع الانفاق ورفح
الفلسطينيه ورفح المصريه سنحاول بعد
الفاصل ان نتطرق للتاثيرات العمليه سواء
من الناحيه السياسيه او الاجتماعيه او
الامنيه
على مجمل الاهالي المنطقه لنا عوده بعد
هذا الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتنا فيها ابعاد وتداعيات
هدم السلطات المصريه لبيوت في رفح المصريه
محاذيا للحدود مع غزه اللواء اركان حرب
عبد الحميد عمران في في القاهره قبل قليل
اللواء ياسين سند وضع الموضوع في سياق
امني استراتيجي كبير في علاقه مصر مع
اسرائيل مع مع سيناء الى اخره هل تعتقد
بان ما يجري الان في رفح
المصريه من اجراءات سيترك اثر لاجهاض هذا
التوجه الذي كان يشير اليه قبل قليل
اللواء
سند كيف يق بمعنى ماذا يعني اذا كان هناك
مخطط معين تجاه سيناء هذه الخطوات المصريه
والاجراءات جاءت لاجهاض اي توجه ربما بهذا
المعنى في علاقه سينا
بغزه برض يعني مره اخرى اللي علاقه سينا
بغزه وما قيل اكثر من مره عن الحلول
المقترحه واقتطاع جزء من سينا والى اخره
كل هذا الكلام عباره عن احاديث تروى
وتتناقل عن ان فلان قال ل فلان وفلان قال
فلان ولا يوجد ورقه واحده رسميه تقول هذا
الكلام لو ندور ونبحث في التاريخ كله
مافيش حاجه تقول هذا الكلام ان دائما يقول
ان فلان الرئيس فلان اعطى وعد ان يقتطع
جزء من السي ب هو برايك هو من باب من باب
التخويف غير
المدعوم حقيقه هو هذا يعني للا نفس
الفلسطينيين اعلنوا اكثر من مره قالوا
احنا لو نسيب الارض بتاعتنا ورو نستوطن في
غزه نبقى خو للارض بتاعتنا نبقى خونا
الوطن بتاعنا فهم ما عندهمش استعداد
يعملوا هذا الكلام ومصر ما عندهاش استعداد
تعمل هذا الكلام اطلاقا ولا تفكر فيه لكن
للاسف في الاصوات كثير من الاصوات التي
تتداول احداث لم تحدث ول تحدث ويفضل
تكرارها مره واثنين وثلاثه دون مالك هذا
الكلام لن يحدث ولكن مصر طبعا زي ما
بقول مازلنا حتى هذه اللحظه والى ان يتغير
التاريخ والى ان يتغير الوضع الجغرافي
والعسكري اسرائيل مازالت هي العدو المحتمل
الرئيسي
لمصر ولكن اسمحي اسمح لي حضره اللواء يعني
هل هل هل يمكن ان ان نضع الخطوات المصريه
رغم هذا البعد الامني الستراتيجي التي
اشرنا اليه الى بعد ظرفي ان صح التعبير هو
العلاقه المتوتره حاليا بين القياده
السياسيه الجديده في في مصر وبين حركه
حماس التي تدير قطاع غزه هل يمكن ان نضع
هذا العامل في الاعتبار بلا
جدال قد يكون هذا العامل يعني عامل طرفي
خالص وجانبي خالص لكن هو المقصد الرئيسي
اللي بتعمله الحكومه هو الدفاع عن امن مصر
القومي قد يتضرر من هذا الكلام اهل سيناء
واحنا يعني معاهم في تضررهم ونستشعر
يتضررون لكن هم ايضا يجب ان يفكروا في امن
مصر المهدد امن مصر حقيقه مهدد في نقطه بس
عاوز اثرها يعني ان ليس كل من يعتدي على
الجنود المصريين في سيناء هم ارهابيين او
قاعده او شء هذا القب عندما تم الاعتداء
على ال 16 جندي مصري اللي استشهد رمضان
الماضي كتبت مقاله وقلت وجهت كلامي لرئيس
مصري قلت له لا لا تستدرج الى سخف سيناء
ليسوا اهل سيناء هم من فعل هذا من فعل هذا
هم المستعربين
الاسرائيليين نكايه في الجيش المصري ووضعك
انت في موقف حرج وظهرك لحقق ف ما تدفعش
بالقوات المصريه اللي داخل سينا اهل
السناء يحبون الجيش المصري اصلا لعشرات
السنين اما يدخل الجيش المصري ويقصد
الحلال ويقتل 32 واحد هؤلاء لهم اهل ولهم
عشائر ولهم قبائل وسوف تسعى الى اار
لهم نعم هناك ايضا هناك ايضا حضره اللواء
جانب جانب مهم فيما يتعلق بالانفاق
و هذه التجاره الكبيره بين رفح المصريه
ورفح الفلسطينيه الكتور نصار واضح ان هذا
بزنس كبير ومستفيد منه كثير من من
الفلسطينيين في غزه وبالتاكيد وكثير من
المصريين وبعض الارقام
التي يشار اليها عن عائدات هذا هذه
التجاره ارقام كبيره م صحيح بالطبع اصبحت
هناك لوبيات تدافع عن عن مثل هذه التجاره
بتقديرك اتخاذ خطوات كالتي اتخذت الان هل
يمكن ان تثير حفيظه هؤلاء بما يجعلهم ربما
يتصرفون بطريقه قد لا تكون امنه للامن
المصري بطبيعه الحال ما انا قلته في
البدايه استاذ محمد انه لابد من التعامل
مع مساله الامن القومي المصري بكلياتها لا
ناخذ جزئيات فقط ونتعامل معه طريقه
التعامل مع مساله الانفاق انا في تصوري
طريقه خاطئه يعني فكره غلق الانفاق انا
معه 100% ولكن لابد من ايجاد بديل طبيعي
وعادي وعلى فكره نفسه اكثر من قياده في
قيادات حماس قالت انها مع فكره غلق
الانفاق لانها في في البدايه ممكن تؤدي
الى مشاكل وكما ذكر سياده ال ممكن يتم
تهريب بعض الاسلحه منها مخدرات الى اخره
انما في الاساس لابد من ايجاد بديل
العنوان الاكبر في هذا هو التعاطي مع
المساله بشكل خاطئ يجب ان تصحح الاداره
المصريه التعامل معه وخصوصا الجيش لانه
هذا يزيد حاله العنف بزياده ان كما قال
السدت اللي عبد الحميد فكره ان يكون هناك
حاله ثقر في التعامل مع انت حينما تضرب
هذه المنازل بهذه الطريقه ولا تجد لهم
بدائل بيجي ب بحاله شحناء بين المصريين
بعضهم وبعض فاذا لابد من التعامل مع كل
المساله على بعضها والجلوس مع مشايخ
القبائل هناك لايجاد حل جذري اما التعامل
بهذه الطريقه انا اظن انه يضر الامن
القومي المصري من جانب ويتيح الفرصه
للاسرائيليين ان يتدخلوا في هذا الملف
وهذا مما يكون له خطوره في المستقبل
القريب نعم اللواه ياسين سند في في باريس
هل تعتقد استكمالا لما قاله الان دكتور
نصار من ان هذه الخطوات الامنيه لابد ان
تصاحب بحوار مع الفعاليات هناك في في رفح
مع العشائر ومع حزمه اجتماعيه ايضا تجعل
هذه الخطوه مقبوله على الاقل في المدى
المتوسط متفق معاه تماما ولازم يكون في
حزمه من الاجراءات والمعبر اتفتح بصفه
دائمه
والحقيقه المخابرات العامه عمرها ما توقفت
عن الحوار مع الاخوه في حماس في كل الظروف
وكل الفصائل مش حماس بس المشكله دلوقتي ان
الشعب الشعب الفلسطيني اللي يعني بدا يزهق
من حماس ومن فتح يعني دي مشكله كبيره لازم
بقى يتفقوا علشان خاطر نقدر نتكلم مع في
اسرائيل بطرف واحد ما يبقاش كل واحد
بيتكلم بوطين فطبعا دي من المشاكل الحقيقه
الكبيره اللي تواجه مصر دلوقتي عشان تحل
المشكله الحاجه الثانيه والاهم ان جميع
القبائل والعواقب في سيناء يعشقوا الجيش
المصري وزي ما قال الاخ برض اللوا عبد
الحميد ا اسرائيل ليست بعيده عن المخطط
الاولاني بتاع 16 جندي بدليل ان العربيه
برض قبلها في واقعه كانت سابقه عربيه طلعت
طلعت الطياره ضربتها في الحال فيعني ده ما
بنقولش احنا ما بنبر اسرائيل اسرائيل طبعا
في مصلحتها عدم الاستقرار لمصر فاحنا
عندنا يعني تشعب كبير جدا في العوامل اللي
بتواجهها القياده المصريه من اجل الحفاظ
على الامن القومي المصري نعم
على ذكر هذا التشعب على ذكر هذا التشعب
بعد اذنك ننهي مع اللواء اركان حرب عبد
الحميد عمران باختصار هل تعتقد بان
السلطات المصريه قادره على تطويق هذا
الموضوع الخاص برفح دون تداعيات خطيره على
الامن
المصري يعني تطويق موضوع رفح بالذات ممكن
اه اقول لكن انا مازلت باندي وبوجه برض
الكلام لخ الفريق اول
السيسي الانتباه الى عدم تمكين اسرائيل من
استدراج الجيش المصري الى فخ سيناء
اسرائيل مازال الجرح اللي في قلبها كبير
من حرب اكتوبر 73 وانتصار الجيش المصري
وهي تريد ان تزيل من على الذاكره العربيه
كلها هذا الانتصار وهذا لا يتاتى الا بذن
او حصار او ووريه الجيش المصري في داخل
سيناء مره تانيه والثار مما حدث لاس شكرا
لك في حرب 76 شكرا لك اللواء اركان حرب
عبد الحميد عمران كنت معنا من القاهره
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا في باريس اللواء ياسين
سند وضيفنا هنا في الاستديو الدكتور جمال
نصار بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
س